hi everyone in this video we're going to
talk about the humoral immunity which is
also known as the antibody mediated
immunity okay so the concept of humoral
immunity was developed based on the
analysis of antibacterial activity of
serum components and the seminal work
was done by Hans Buckner in early 70s he
found out that components in the blood
or the serum and he turned them as
alexinnz they have protective roles
against pathogenic attack so he thought
these soluble substances which are
present in serum or body fluids they
could be very important to provide
immunity to an individual later on paul
erage time them has complement proteins
and now we know that complement proteins
are very important for our immunity
right and that's a part of broadly like
the innate immune system now these
concepts was the pillars for a humoral
immunity what we know today about
humoral immunity came from this early
work by Paul enriched and many
colleagues now antibodies are versatile
effector molecules in terms of immune
response so let's see that how
antibodies can be useful tools for the
immune system to encounter one pathogen
or to neutralize one infection so first
mechanism by which antibody works is by
blocking the pathogen entry into the
cell it is also termed as neutralization
we'll elaborate on all of these points
gradually secondly by coating the
pathogen surface with antibody make
these pathogens weak are opsin eyes
later on they can be killed by antibody
mediated site
city or ADCC mechanism lastly antibodies
can also help in complement fixation
which would ultimately destroy the
pathogen so all of these are the
possible mechanisms by which the humoral
immune response can be triggered so
let's take all of these points into
account in a lot more detail so let's
say there is a virus and the virus need
to interact with this receptor to gain
entering the cell now if the virus
cannot interact with the receptor there
is no question that the virus can enter
the cell and many of the antibodies
which are against these viral surface
antigens can block the virus but mean by
not letting it interact with the cell
receptor and as a result the viral entry
is prevented so this is one of the
framework by which antibodies could be
very useful to boost an immune response
secondly there could be other mechanisms
for example optimized pathogens for
example a virus is optimized or coated
with antibodies and that can be up taken
by several cells such as dendritic cells
because dendritic cells can phagocytose
right other cells which has FC receptor
now if c receptor is against the tail of
the antibody which is known as FC region
these FC receptors can ultimately lead
to endocytosis of the whole oxidized
pathogen by neutrophil macrophages NK
cells or even dendritic cells so quite a
lot of cells which has FC receptor can
update these oxidized pathogen and can
neutralize the threat okay
the next method by which the pathogen
can be neutralized is antibody mediated
complement fixation so on the surface
proteins of a bacteria let's say
antibodies can bind and antibodies can
serve as a platform for buying new
classical components of the complement
system complement proteins such as c1q
can bind to the end of the antibody and
ultimately with a complicated cascade
event it would create membrane
pores in the bacteria as a result the
bacteria would be lized and there would
be pressure disbalance building up over
all the bacteria would be nice and the
bacteria would be dead so this is how
complement mediated lysis of a pathogen
can take place with the help of
antibodies okay so we at least learned
about what are the possible ways by
which humoral immune response can work
so let's talk about the potential of the
antibodies in terms of neutralizing
pathogens or complement fixation so if
we talk about complement fixation then
IgM has higher potential than ihe G
versions because IgM can interact with a
lot more antigen simultaneously than IgG
right so it is isotype dependent and
also affinity dependent right guys now
let me tell you that these kind of
immunity can also be transferred from
mom to the baby because when the baby is
there enough inside the mom's womb then
IgG antibodies from mother's body can
travel across the placenta and can move
into the newborn and that can give them
immunity also iga secreted in the cold
trunk can provide immunity to the
newborn in the initial tails so these
kind of immunity can be transmitted from
mother to the baby right now let's talk
about kinetics of these kind of humoral
immune response in that we are going to
take a simple example let's say we are
exposed by a pathogen okay now
immediately antibody production does not
happen so it takes a little bit of time
aprox 10 days when the antibody
generation starts and initially the
antibodies are IgM category or IgM
isotype later on IgG antibodies are
produced and it takes almost 10 days
after pathogen exposure from pathogen
exposure it takes 10 days for this
response to happen
you must be wondering why why it is a
delay why that is late and why this
humoral immune system is so slow
let me tell you the reason behind this
lag okay so imagine there is a trust in
you and which is splitting in your skin
and there is some amount of pathogens
let's say activity or virus gain access
inside your body
so just beneath your body there are many
antigen presenting cells like
macrophages and dendritic cells which
would recognize the pathogen but
ultimately it has to take the pathogen
grind that pathogen out and display its
pathogenic determinants on the MHC
molecules then these dendritic cells can
migrate all along the blood vessels and
it can go to the army base camp which is
the lymph node now inside the lymph node
it would interact with the T cells and
it would activate the T cells right T
cells would then activate the B cells
now after B cell is activated quickly
some amount of and B cells would be
produced into plasma cells some amount
of B cells would be instantly produced
instantly converted to a plus itself the
plasma cell would secrete the antibody
that can go to the circulation but
eventually the bezel which is activated
would get expanded clonally there would
be clonal expansion they would
proliferate massively and when time
comes they can eventually match your
into antibody producing plasma cells and
then this process is known as
differentiation in between this process
there are many fine tunings which would
enhance that affinity of these
antibodies which are produced and also
there would be different isotype
switching reactions happening in this
place but overall this whole process
this complicated process takes quite a
lot of time that's why there is a lag in
between the pathogenic exporer from from
the pathogenic exposure to the antibody
production so there is a lag of 10 days
and that is why we see these responses
are specific but bit slower because
there is antigen detection there is
antigen transport to the lymph node and
there would be differentiation of the B
cell and then only the antibody can be
secreted into the serum right so this is
overall why
this is the reason for which the humoral
immune response is bit slower now let's
quickly revise that what we learned so
we learn the humoral immune response
have different kind of ways by which it
can work for example one effect was the
neutralization where antibody binds to
the pathogen and kind of neutralize it
either prevent it from entering our cell
all kind of opsin eyes it's such that it
becomes 3 right this is one method
second method is like a second method we
already discussed which is like actually
opsonization now coating the pathogen
surface with antibodies would make the
pathogen very weak and not allowing it
to interact with the cell surface
receptor such that it cannot get inside
the cells and lastly there could be
complement fixation if there is
complement fixation there could be
complement mediated lysis of these cells
right and ultimately there is antibody
dependent cycle toxicity now obsolete
pathogens can be uptaken by several
sales like us like I say neutrophil
macrophage in yourselves or dendritic
cells and as a result what would happen
the pathogen would be neutralized so
when we talked about humoral immunity we
have to keep in mind all of these
possible ways by which human immune
response can work and I hope you enjoyed
this video this was a overview of
humoral immunity if you liked this video
give it a big thumbs up don't forget to
Like share and subscribe and do let me
know in the comment I mean do let me
know in the comment how you have my
videos thanks you thank you guys